[Music]
three two one action
they got something backed off the record
where we talk about what is so ugly your
hair's like the other guy no my hair is
ugly looks so stupid at least you don't
have a hole on both sides here the hole
I tried cutting my own hair did you miss
it looks dull what you looked even
better as a whole this is like a week in
the beginning kind of hide it no I'm
wearing my hat cuz this part which I
didn't but I can't you can't Stella cuz
I was gonna say your hat covers
everything but the holes I know guys
just crawl it out let's be a biker gang
please or go back to your cholo days and
just shave it no I done that for like so
many years already you don't look like a
biker though I get like a what a
dictator I know me I get like like a
like a Yakuza virus I'm sure yeah yeah
sure I do it I definitely do yes you
said you boozing gambling if I was white
then it's a biker but no it's cuz I got
sunburned so my back is really easy you
should be a part of Greece with that
white shirt oh yeah have you just been
going up everything yes oh my face yeah
I think I haven't shaved this in three
weeks now yeah and my hair has been over
a month and a half you're just gonna
keep growing it I'm just gonna go man
because um my inspiration for my hair is
samurai style not like the old like a
ballroom a shave everything away from
the whole biker gang thing it's yeah I'm
just gonna go in [ __ ] not man bun
but like samurai like black bun ponytail
just call it there we go no it's it's
it's a little bit different because what
they'll do is you you get like this much
hair and then you wrap it straight like
a ponytail
and so it looks like a ponytail yeah man
1 no it's not a man man but
dick I see but but people with long man
buns end up doing that like 10 did that
for a while we had a rubber band they
tied it like let's see no it's not a bun
a bun looks like a tootsie roll I mean a
cinnamon roll on their back Cinnabon
Cinnabon oh so delicious
it's so good it's a man button without
the stigma of a man bun yeah cuz I just
want to try it and wear samurai armor
and dofollow should you have your that's
why I'm like let's go full on tight yeah
have any of you guys gained weight I
came like a like 10,000 weight my love
but I could feel it I could see it in my
face I have attack and I never actually
like step on a scale though no I gained
10 pounds I can do this and then I can
tell how much like the rolls are thicker
is that how you check it yep
I don't need a step - get all you didn't
step on us got no I stepped on a scale
cuz I I was just like damn I think I
feel kind of like chunkier and I just
stepped on a scale my oh how long did it
take maybe like a month it's like the
first the first month I was eating a
pretty clean still so I was like mainly
protein veggies lean meats and then [ __ ]
it and then after a while like I had all
my like apocalypse food and I'm like if
I don't eat this apocalypse food come on
you know I like the whole grocery store
like chaos it died down right yeah so
I'm like alright you don't really need
all this apocalypse food anymore so I
start eating the instant noodles the
frozen pies starting all kinds oh you
got pie yeah we got pie and everything
in it I have the opposite problem like
if I don't actively try to put on weight
I lose weight so I just bought a scale
recently too because I was like oh
what's going on right now I think I lost
like five pounds this thing started that
used to be no I eat but like I have to
try to to eat in a way to gain weight
it's like if I don't work out constantly
I lose muscle mass really fast at least
muscle mass really fast - but I gained
fat really really fast never seen it I
never see it every time you always
complain you're like oh I'm getting
fatter I'm like this is where you can
tell that about yourself yeah you're
right I think Kasey has phantom fat yes
yeah because he was fat so yes that's
fat I've been fat and then puberty
stretched me out and you got skinny
there in puberty and then la lifestyle
just got me fat again when I moved out
here so I'm like I've gotten fat skinny
fat skinny I for sure don't want to go
back through that cycle again so like
I'm super self-conscious about you see
the fatness you're like I gotta cut it
out but it's so hard now though it's
like drinking every day that's actually
why I think I've gotten a lot more
rounders because of the drinking yeah
I'm definitely up my drinking which cuz
I would net forever this calorie-dense
juice like with the horn cause it
doesn't really matter
definitely juice and also the food
you're eating after marathon yeah yeah
Jesus I I used to have trouble eating in
the past remember what we always talked
about it I think you startled me I just
finished your five through unless that's
true I know thank you a lot more than
what you don't cuz she would bite one
taco and leave the whole taco there yeah
I would literally eat like a bird so you
go to Chipotle order the kids milk it's
too much food yes
kids you could pay a lot of gear too
much it's always a kid's meal well why
don't you just pay more for less than
you can you can't pay let's do it laughs
hey morph a little order only one taco
and that [ __ ] will last me for like five
meals I'm like this is too much food but
anyway you ever thought about just
ordering less toppings man so if there's
less food yeah I do
it's just the base the baseline how much
meat they give her how much beans much
plainer right and they're making that
the food process that Chipotle do you go
now it's too much food is it they put
the tortilla there too much food period
so that's why I complained but yeah I do
consume a lot more now than I ever taste
two bytes instead of one that's doubling
that's quite no it's um sometimes I'll
actually finish my whole plate and I'm
like whoa myself but then I am not
fitting in my clothes look at this face
like my my clothes don't fit that well
anymore we're making up for all the food
that you did any exactly cuz like I have
a lot of like tank tops or like
tight-fitting like really tight clothes
that now I don't want to wear cuz I feel
like roles are coming out oh [ __ ] for me
I like 510 pounds difference like up or
down doesn't make a huge difference in
how I look so for me I can't tell those
are step on a scale but then even then
it's just like for you guys you guys are
at like a healthy weight that like you
could tell if you put help you -
probably made some loose [ __ ] on my body
now imma have a go I do remember when
you're really big no yeah I was very
yeah it was like there's that one part
like oh we're all like bulkiness out
down Paul Jay King news videos that
people [ __ ] take clips so funny crazy
thing you see always has ABS it's like
you know what he's fat yeah you still
see it for me it's a I lose like 50
pounds you won't see anything did you
only ever gain a layer of fat here where
you don't roll form into
it's like tyka yeah F was born with ABS
dude yeah that guy's like little as in
his like little he's little you taught
him how to flex like that did you guys
know like I was just working on I think
he just sees me and so he's like we
taught him the flex and he goes he
actually does it he does this thing and
he pops his shoulder up and he goes
about it like he's learned because
remember when Isaac was so so little and
you guys had just open barbell and then
he was able to lift the entire like the
bar bar bar yeah and I remember thinking
like man if you guys ever have a kid
like I'm pretty sure this kid's gonna be
working out with you because you work
out all the time does he ever join you I
try to teach him a push up but I think
he's too dumb to know how to do it yet
cuz like I was teaching them young and
dumb something like this and then I'm
like I'm doing a push-up right and it
goes like this
[Laughter]
I'm just locked in I don't think he
understands how to like my elbows can
bend that way in like in kindergarten
going to PE for the first time all these
kids hop in the ground everyone no one
knows how to do a push them they're all
just like humping the ground like are we
doing it right there are a lot of adults
that geezers like yeah hey guys they're
moving I mean he moves a lot so I think
he's getting his like his muscles or his
working out somehow he's a super active
kid I know and you guys are swimming a
lot cuz you add Tanner do I like weight
doctor I swim every day pop probably
every day or every other that's the best
[ __ ] like every other day at least so I
got so hot to my workout and when in my
circuits
I have a pool part of it now so I swim
at least at that part yeah I saw you
doing the thing where you were treading
around right in like a square I've just
been doing all kinds of like
fun stuff in the pool and like when
you're sweaty and you jump in the pony
come out like when you're done with the
circuit you're actually not drenched
like you actually feel like cooled off
so it feels really really good
what's cool right now you can actually
work out and then order your food before
you even start working out and it'll
arrive by the time you're done working
out because any loss may take as a post
my live dream is quarantine yeah because
we already started drinking right and
then we're already kind of like messed
up but we don't want to go out a drive
over responsible so the best person that
hit up is post mates have to deliver the
food they deliver the drinks and we
could stay home be safe right so if
you're like me you probably start
thinking about what to eat for dinner
while you're eating lunch because I love
food and that's why I love using pulse
mates they deliver food from every
restaurant I can think of right to my
door but post mates doesn't just deliver
burgers and sushi they actually make my
life easier with grocery delivery or
whatever I can think of delivery to
convenience stores clothing stores you
name it
so no more trips to the store no more
late-night fast-food runs or beer runs I
don't even have to worry about where to
grab lunch anymore
just download post mates on iOS or
Android find your favorites and get
anything you want delivered within an
hour for a limited time post mates is
giving our listeners $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days to
start your free deliveries download the
app and use the code off the record
that's the code off the record for $100
of free delivery credit with no minimum
purchase for your first 7 days when you
down the post mates app anything you
need anytime you need it
post mates it
I've made so much oh my gosh
like I like a favorite thing yellow go
to think no I don't ever choose the
fluid I just have my girlfriend
transferred she's the one with the
cravings like I like making food but
it's just like I don't my cravings are
never enough where I'm like I need this
now really you never go I need a [ __ ]
cinnamon roll no I want things fine I
don't need things you know like any of
her cravings are become needs I post
mates boba probably every other day
really every time I get it geo goes
you're so [ __ ] Asian I'm like I know
I went to Magic Mountain for cinnamon
rolls anything but like recently um I
had this freaking nasty-ass hangover
because we drink a little too much oh
yeah and the next day I was like I must
have fat burger and then I looked on
pace
what post mates and it was close some
days yeah but they like for me in a
Friday got fat burger huh you get a fat
Friday get fat fat fatty move further
away from all their using spots so we
have like Asian I have like I get Panda
Express cuz I'm a miss like Asian food
well we had like tasty garden we had all
the like bomb Asian spots so I used to
get that every single day the curry from
there is like bomb yeah I know you
randomly across okay oh you guys have
post me too I'll call you got the story
we haven't posted it alcohol yeah we
have it so what do they do they check
your ID well I haven't check your ID we
go to the liquor store and pick up and
then you get more selection by going in
person cuz on online I don't think they
don't put their entire inventory for you
to pick you know what's [ __ ] dope
about our city there's uh those
old-school drive-thru I don't know what
they're calling dairies or whatever but
you actually don't have to get out of
your car and there's a lot of them no no
no like like you know like a grocery
store liquor stores yeah
cereal all of his gorgeous and there's a
bunch of them which is crazy
drive up you're like hey give me a
[ __ ] half-and-half
give me some chips and give me some gum
yeah and always looks decrepit at least
now the ones I've seen
they're all old but there there's a
bunch and I'm like so you do not the
other car was really cool I stole pork
rinds from one of those you did I ran a
big rabbit and ran away yeah no I like
me my friend we ran up and we grabbed a
whole bet you know how they have the
whole rack of things I just grabbed I
hugged it and I [ __ ] ran so much that
all the chips fell and I was left with
two bags yeah I don't know dude I was
stupid as [ __ ] what was I like nine
years old
Oh what yeah I was like nine or ten I
was like what fourth or little birth or
fifth grade that's crazy I started
stealing when I was in maybe fourth
grade - yeah it was terrible man you
know it's funny the guy at that that
works there or he owns the spot his pair
of what do you call it like he knows my
friends brothers my friend's brother
went to pick up cigarettes and he got
scolded Oh your brother came here
[ __ ] every day the draw was like um
well my parents are crazy strict so I
would never get what I wanted so I just
started stealing little things that I
just want like baseball cards whatever
just got bigger than being a bigger I
really go shoe store and they'll be like
those do are those little like metal
things that you attach those little like
puppet things to and you throw them on
the floor they have like a little
missile type B and you put it in there
those pop yeah look at them and like
open the like the package and just take
it put in my pocket
hey chill in the neighborhood anymore
like just go [ __ ] that's all I don't
call of duty yeah pretty much
Isaac never hangs on a thing damn cuz we
would go right I try to get him I know
right
I had dragon when I went to your house
to pick up lemons that day you had to
drag him out to come hang out you know
what I mean I'm a dragon but lucky just
you it was an instant
oh and then I'll lay eyes and be good to
get out and breathe some air being the
Sun lay little he would have wanted to
see me memorize the can I hung out on
the neighborhood all the time it was
just like we were just luring seems like
do people do that or is maybe it's an LA
thing they don't do it out here no what
if I you I'd like the only boss I play
catch or like an activity like you in
the beginning of this whole quarantine
thing he loved riding the bike and we
would be riding the bike frequently yeah
but now I can't even try to get him to
go out she does that with other kids
yeah cuz I remember seeing a ton of kids
just on bicycles like you'll see groups
of fire like Sandlot style just all all
over the [ __ ] city like a group of
kids in our new neighborhood where
they're speeding so it's like a skating
like little group skateboarding but
recently though yeah if they skate their
moms like you better stay six feet yeah
cuz it sounds like our new community
every house is like freaking like I
could throw less than a six feet so the
houses have to move yeah he'll need to
move no but it's like really really
really close confined like plots right
and and so we have seen other kids that
are around Isaac's age or I'm like [ __ ]
man if it wasn't for this whole thing
like she probably would be making
friends around the neighborhood because
all that we've we've talked to some
neighbors as they're walking by like and
at distance and there's a lot of people
they're like oh man we can't wait til
this is lifted so we can do a block
party where I was like people do like
movies and TV until he told me he grew
up with block parties I'm like that's a
big these girls they have that a lot of
people you'll get a block party that's
my experience and then you get to as the
ones talking to us about block party
my neighbors my my sister live in Rhode
Island and then she's like yeah it's
like it's this thing where it's almost a
responsibility if you live in that kind
of neighborhood and you have to be part
of the neighborhood yes part of the
community minds yeah so there's a block
party you have to go out and mingle with
your neighbors and then she grew up over
here and she's like I don't want to go
out there and talk to these neighbors
and stand out there in the Sun all day
but it's just part of what cuz if you
don't do it do they look at you like
what's wrong you're not
you're not part of the community and
they won't look after you anymore like
you know because then I think the idea
is to also like a wolf I member out of
town or whatever like I you know I would
call upon you to help you know make sure
my house is okay and vice versa in a
minute we're not there to like to be at
the block parties I think you're kind of
like that's where like you're you're a
leper you're just going that's why I
like living in this new neighborhood
though it's made me feel so much more
connected to the community I live in
because I I've never grown up with even
knowing who the [ __ ] my next-door
neighbor was ever but now I know like
the vicinity of like ten houses around
me like I know all the neighbors and to
the point where I recently I didn't know
this but Casey left the garage remote in
his like one of his shorts when I was
doing the laundry and so my next door
neighbor hits me up and she's like hey I
don't know why were your garage doors
acting a little weird but again closing
winning and closing I saw was that your
garage door was open and I was like what
the [ __ ] what was it open like I was I
was telling you I'm like I think our
garage is broken
howling there's a glitch checking you
found that home but then later like a
couple hours later when I was finally
drying the clothes then I found the
remote I'll look this is what it was but
I love that so was going off in the
dryer my neighborhood is super nice like
that too like my name is surprisingly
Lyle is on a neighborhood battle right
now definitely way better but it's super
nice because when I was first looking
for my house the first thing I saw that
I noticed I liked about the neighborhood
was that people there everyone was
walking around outside walking their
dogs and stuff and it's normally like a
good sign for me to be like that's a
nice neighborhood and just a couple days
ago this my neighbor passed by he's like
hey I found that you left your circular
saw outside so I've moved it behind your
fence so no one would take it
I used it first and I built the
treehouse and then I brought it back I
saw that you left it on your workshop
table and your garage door was open so I
decide to hide it for you before I made
this project
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]